je pèse en gaule je tombe sur toi je
vais en egypte me met des bâtons dans
les roues maintenant tu m'empêche
d'envahir la bretagne tu a clairement
décidé de me pourrir la vie
c'est comme ça ces aventures d'astérix
et pour les aventures de césar les
aventures d'astérix
rocchi souhaiterions pour quatre îlots
des romains tout d'abord
c'est la magic potion je présume
excellente nouvelle que vous parlez à
l'envers je demande votre cadeau
aux blacks bon ça donne une seconde
chance et bon soir tu suis un mec
honnête c'est un très bon choix
compagnons sont gallois il est facile de
le deviner les élections non halal
d'heure